our friend Sawyer Hartman is coming by
today who is a professional photographer
and youtuber who's been doing this for a
long long time the person who eats the
lemon puts themselves on the registry as
somebody who will donate bone marrow in
the event that they're a match it's I
mean it's a surgical process it's kind
of a terrifying experience our friend
Sawyer Hartman is coming by today who is
a professional photographer and youtuber
who's been doing this for a long long
time he's gonna talk from the
perspective of a photographer but what I
think is really interesting about this
bit is that if you listen closely as a
non photographer you can see the
techniques that he uses in everyday
things like shows movies websites
advertisement all over the place it's
really this sense that as a photographer
you aren't just taking photos you're
visualizing culture today we're gonna
teach you something about photography my
mom took photos my entire life she
always had a camera her hands and when I
was about 10 my mom took me to
Yellowstone National Park and I had a
Canon Rebel X film camera a little DSLR
or SLR back then and I remember I saw
moose and all these people were behind
this rope taking pictures of this moose
I was small enough I went under the rope
through bushes and like two hours later
got close enough to the moose as soon as
he lifted his head I got a shot and it
like filled the whole frame and ever
since then like I've loved photography I
brought a little book with me I keep my
notes in because I wanted to give you
guys like practical things that you
really could be using and need to know
as a photographer tip number one is
until you really know what you're doing
with your settings in your camera turn
the dial the setting called AV put you
in a couple of different lighting
scenarios and show how the camera
[ __ ] does it for you
yeah you set where you want the f-stop
right and then it changes all of the
other settings to make it expose if I
take a photo of him here on manual I
have to keep adjusting my settings when
really all I care about is depth of
field span yeah right there
traditionally is a hard shot but you can
see the cameras still exposes perfectly
I didn't know about it for like seven
years changed my life a big moment for
me in getting better at photography and
filmmaking you got to understand how the
lens is going to make the audience feel
and then design your shots so that they
can actually feel it I would recommend
you get your hands on 14 24 and 35 50
and
85 and a 135 when someone says I need a
photo of this and I want people to feel
like this you'll go give me the 50 like
I was saying it's important when you're
learning focal length to understand
what's used for what type of shot this
35 millimeter lens let's pretend the MTA
that little house in the back
that's a waterfall we want to get 35 we
can get a shot that makes it all about
our subject and the location it's
interacting together but when we switch
to a 50 there's so much blurrier and
compressed it's really become a photo
about our subject and subject only then
when you shoot on something like a 200
mil it's literally just the subject just
the headshot nothing in the background
can even be seen this tip will help
solve the issue of your photos looking
like everyone else's photos when you
shoot in the same location now I know a
lot of photographers when they roll up
somewhere they want to get the photo
everyone else is taking this is fine for
safety once you have that photo crawl
into a bush and shoot through the leaves
get behind a railing it just find some
way to interact with your environment
it's kind of break up your photography
and just have fun by using things like a
prism or these things I found on Amazon
that make really cool colors you can
actually figure out how by using things
like this and using these weird as weird
tools you can start to give your photos
a really nice personality paint with
light and color your a black and white
photographer if you've ever even
experimented with black and white
photography then you know light is very
very important it's the reason that I am
now highlighted in this frame in the
hallway and things in the background
don't really seem important if you put a
light at the end of the hallway behind
somebody and you highlighted one thing
well that could make it look like you're
trying to get someone to look back there
yeah exactly see how the warm and cold
contrasts actually separate me from the
scene if you're taking a photo of just
completely snow-covered fields if you
put someone or with a bright orange
jacket and they just pop you can easily
remember this rule because painting with
light and painting with color both seek
to add contrast to your photo
okay last one
stop shooting thousands of photos a day
I do it too and recently in the last
year and a half I've started losing my
inspiration to bring my camera with me
when I go shoot for an hour and a half
of the model at sunset I'll come home
which may be 1200 photos out of the 1200
photos they'll be four or five that I
want to use and the process of narrowing
down those photos to the one you want to
edit is actually more challenging than
taking the photo in the first place
something I did to be able to restart my
own creativity was the other day I went
out and I bought a 1972 Polaroid camera
what's important is the roll of film
only holds eight photos
finding the one ship when you only have
eight shots to take it actually brings
in a whole nother layer of confidence
you can start figuring out what might
look good what you think looked good
before and you start building yourself
like a little catalog of knowledge of
what makes a good photograph when you
shoot on things like this and when you
bring that to things like digital it can
save you a ton of time ask yourself what
do you want your photo to say where are
you is it somewhere dangerous is it
somewhere safe do you feel safe do you
want your audience to feel safe these
are all simple things that you need to
start asking yourself so you can create
a photo that actually like makes people
feel you're just starting out don't feel
bad about shooting thousands of photos
it's very very important that you come
to understand the settings and how your
camera work but once you have the skill
for one week put in a four gig card or
even a two gig card and leave it in
there the whole week and you're only
gonna have maybe 50 photos to play with
here's the deal here's the deal
shonduras nominated us to participate in
the lemons for leukemia challenge you
eat a lemon and you call out three other
people who then do the same thing to
raise awareness for bone marrow donation
to help save lives of people affected by
leukemia but I think it's only right
that if we accept the challenge the
person who eats the lemon puts
themselves on the registry as somebody
who will donate bone marrow in the event
that they're matched process right well
they're breaking your bone yeah they
inject you with the needle that's like
this long shove the needle vertically
through your femur through your blood I
think
the side effects of donating bone marrow
could be from what I've read you could
feel like you're getting over a cold
that you could feel fatigued and tired
for up to a month carmichael our brave
brave boy Carmichael has decided that he
will sign up I think we're gonna pass it
on three more people volunteering I want
to volunteer
let me Google the side effects of it
your body your choice more than ten
thousand people in the US a year are
diagnosed with life-threatening diseases
such as Leukemia and Lymphoma for which
a stem cell transplant is the best and
only treatment of trouble walking for a
few days
no more standing desk but it may take a
couple of weeks before you feel fully
recovered but you can save a life you
could save someone's life
joining really donate you
then I agree
back for this huh know what doesn't go
right in oh yes all right
go right in oh wait I wasn't recording
oh you were recording no I'm just
kidding oh you weren't recording let's
do it again
mm-hmm I challenge film riot Anna Akana
and soy hartman good job man are you
doing an iphone4 oh yeah of course
oh you really put me through a wringer
today huh it's one thing to say I can do
it so if I can get the split just right
I might be able to make it look like
there's two of them it's always
important to find the strengths of your
camera and if it's not resolution and
its size put it in some really weird
places
are you comfortable sitting here I'm
just trying to find the lines of where I
am and try to accentuate it the reason
this shots interesting is because all
the fences all of these poles all the
lines everything draws your eye directly
to hip when so it looks at the
photograph there's a lot going on to
interest them but the subjects very
clear we were able to get super close to
the razor wire
whereas before with a different camera I
probably would not have felt comfortable
doing something that's very interesting
to me is because we all hold our phones
we have them with us these are pretty
much our best friends now you will never
get a more natural photo of someone
who's not a professional model than if
you take it on an iPhone if I ask
someone to take my picture with my 1dx I
look like a deer in headlights who
doesn't know what to do you snap a photo
of me on an iPhone I probably didn't
even notice that's gonna be my profile
picture that's it I hope you guys learn
something if you're interested in
finding out more head on over to
Sawyer's channel where he puts his
techniques to the test check it out give
him a like I'm sure he'd appreciate